- Whats weirdest thing
you found yourself doing in quarantine?
Cause I have found myself
doing some incredibly odd
things that I never would have done.
But there's just you know,
sometimes you're forced into it.
- Let me tell you.
I mean yeah the time
is weird when you're in quarantine.
Luckily I'm writing a memoir
so that's really occupied
a good portion of my time,
which has been fun to
go back over your life
I wish everybody can do this.
Not that you would have to publish it
- I've never told anybody this
I'm literally been writing
mine like separately
because I was like,
this is such a crazy story.
You're totally right.
You kind of get to go
back through your life.
Isn't that the best,
cause you get to live again,
it's the best.
And then you're also like,
you just hopefully you're wiser,
you know now and you look back
and you're like God,
that seam
- I know
- It's no different then,
- And like getting outside the bubble that
- Oh my God
- The idea that I used to,
there was one time I
was thinking of writing
this story of the day where
I was hitchhiking to kiss
and it was like
You know I had no idea how
I was going to get there.
I had no idea how I was going to get home,
but I had tickets to kiss
and I had this
- (laughing)
and I had to get there. I don't know how.
So I just hitchhiked to put my thumb out
and then some random guy
- Dateline special but okay (laughing).
- You know i had the platform shoes on.
I was ready to rock.
- Oh my God I mean you do.
That's the thing.
When you find yourself
writing about your life,
like even me moving out
to LA I had no idea.
No job.
I had nowhere to live.
but I just went.
I was just like it's just the same.
- You know
- You just have to do it.
- There's something to
being young and dumb,
- 100%
- Right?
Because if you thought
about it I'd be like,
what you did what?
- I would never let my children.
- (laughing) Never
- Well I'm like no you're
not allowed to do that.
- Oh my God